♪ ♪
>> HEADING BACK AT A DEMOCRAT
WHO'S BEEN CRITICAL OF THE
GROUP.
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
SLAMMED BLM ABOUT THE RISING
VIOLENCE AGAINST BLACK
AMERICANS.
RESPONDING TO ADAMS WAS SPEAKING
WITH THEM.
>> LET'S GET BACK TO ERIC ADAMS.
THIS MAYOR WHO IS A DEMOCRAT BUT
HE CHOOSE CONSERVATIVE TALKING
POINTS EASEL WHITE MAN IN BLACK
FACE AND A VERY CONSERVATIVE
MINDED WHITE MAN.
HE HAS 16 SHOOTING VICTIMS ON A
TRAIN AND WHAT HE CAN DO ABOUT
POLICING AND HE SAYS, WHAT ABOUT
BLM?
IS AMERICA NOT SMART ENOUGH TO
SEE THEM DEFLECTING.
>> THE BLM LEADERS CONTINUE TO
DEFUND POLICE AFTER THE MOVEMENT
LED TO A STARTLING SPIKE IN THE
MURDERS OF BLACK AMERICANS.
>> THE COPS ARE NOT THE ANSWER.
FOR PAPER PEOPLE COMMIT CRIMES
OUT OF DESPERATION.
ADDRESS THE POVERTY, THE
REPUBLICANS DON'T CARE.
IT WAS STABLE TEACH YOU TO
EMPOWER YOURSELVES.
DEMOCRATS LIKE YOU BOTH
HANDICAPPED AND CRIPPLED ON
WELFARE.
>> NOT JUST HOW HE BE SOMETIMES
ON TV.
HE SAYS THAT ADAMS PLANET
MONUMENTAL FAILURES, MONTHS INTO
IT THAT MOST OF THE ARREST OF
THE OFFICERS PROGRAM OUR PETTY
CRIMES AND WHAT HE SAYS ARE
VIOLATIONS.
THAT'S A FAILURE THAT ADAMS
POLICIES ARE MAKING THE CITIES
BETTER.
>> Jeanine: UNDERWROTE THAT'S
THE CASE NUMBER ONE.
UNDER NO STREET CRIME OR COPS
THE ANTI-CRIME UNIT REZ ARE
CALLED HISTORICALLY.
IS THERE FOR PETTY CRIMES.
THUS NUMBER ONE, NUMBER TWO.
I FOUND IT FASCINATING THAT WE
DISCLOSE WITH THEM SAYING THAT
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T TEACH AT A
HELP, THOUGH TEDIOUS AND TRY TO
HELP US, BUT THE DEMOCRATS WANT
TO ANYTHING.
I'M NOT SURE HE WANTS.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
WE CAN BLAME THE DEATHS OF BLACK
AMERICANS ON THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT TO
DEFUND THE POLICE.
IT IS THAT SIMPLE.
THERE IS A STATISTICAL REALITY
OF THE FACT THAT ONCE THAT
MOVEMENT STARTED WITH DEFUND
POLICE, MORE BLACKS AND
MINORITIES IN THE INNER CITIES
BEING MURDERED.
THE STATS DO NOT LIE.
AND WHAT SHOCKS ME IS THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO JOIN THE MOVEMENT
WHICH I'VE NO PROBLEM WITH BEING
IN A MOVEMENT IS GOOD, THE
ORGANIZATION IS NOT.
WHY ARE THEY SAYING WHERE'S OUR
MONEY, WHERE THE DONATIONS?
WERE THE PLEDGES.
WHY ARE WE HELPING BLACK LIVES.
AND NOT JUST THOSE ONES THAT
THEY ONE HIGHLIGHT AS
SIGNIFICANT AND AWFUL.
THOSE THAT INVOLVE POLICE.
ACTIVISTS WILL SEE THE OTHER WAY
WITH IT WHEN IT COMES A BLACK
LIVES.
I JUST DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR IT.
I'M SORRY.
YOU WILL BE OUT THERE FIGHTING
FOR ALL BLACK VICTIMS, AND MAY
BE THINGS YOU BUT AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED IS ADAMS DEFLECTING?
YES AND NOTHING IS DONE A GREAT
JOB.
I THINK THE FIRST TIME HE TALKS
ABOUT REALLY MAKING SURE THAT WE
GET PEOPLE TO LOOK ON THE TRAIN.
SO WE HAVE A DECISION TO MAKE WE
EITHER KEEP PRESSURING HIM TO
PROTECT US WE JUST MOVE ON TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
>> ONE THING HE DID SAY IS THAT
THEY BELIEVE THAT THE MOTHER OF
POVERTY, THE MOTHER OF CRIME IS
POVERTY.
AZIMUTH OF THE INTERVIEW, SOME
OF US TALKING POINTS WERE A
LITTLE LESS INCENDIARY A LOT
MORE CAREFUL I GUESS.
BUT HE SAID BASICALLY THE ONLY
REASON THAT THERE'S CRIME IN
NEW YORK CITY IS BECAUSE THERE'S
POVERTY IN NEW YORK CITY AND
POLICE CAN BE THE ANSWER.
>> I DIFFER WITH HIM ON A COUPLE
OF FRONTS.
I THINK MAYOR ADAMS IS NOT
LIMITED DESCRIBE, LOW BIT ABOUT
WHAT THE JUDGE SAID WITH BLM
BEING SOFT FOOTBALL I DO WITH
THE OVERALL POINT OF THE
MOVEMENT OF SOME OF CERTAINLY
SUPPORT MORE THAN INDIVIDUALS.
BUT THAT YOUNG FELLA HAS A RIGHT
TO SHARE HIS VIEWS IS TO SCREW
WITH THEM.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY.
MY FATHER GREW UP POOR, LETTING
GO OUT KILLING PEOPLE AND
ROBBING AND BLOATING.
THEY WANT TO GET AN EDUCATION,
THANK GOD GRACE FAMILIES.
TO SIT UP OR PEOPLE THIS
INDICTMENT OF POOR PEOPLE.
AND INDICTMENT I UNDERSTAND WHAT
IS TRYING TO SAY WE BETTER
POLICIES TO HELP EMPOWER
COMMUNITIES PROVIDE JOBS AND
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES IN
HEALTH CARE.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE WAY YOU SEE
IT.
BUT WE NEED IN THE CITY AND WHAT
OTHER CITIES NEED SOME NEW
FEDERAL CRIME TASK FORCES WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL OFFICIALS.
WE KNEW MORE COPS ON THE
STREETS.
WE KNEW MORE DOLLARS TRAINING
POLICE OFFICERS SO WE CAN AVOID
SOME TRAGEDIES THAT WAS SEEN
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF OR
TWO.
WHEN YOU LOCK UP PEOPLE WHO
COMMIT CRIMES.
EMMY DEMOCRAT AGAIN.
THIS BILL REFORM I THINK THE
MAYOR HAS BEEN OUTRIGHT AGAINST
IT.
HE'S BEEN ALBANY PROTESTING AND
ADVOCATING AGAINST THE LAW.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE GOVERNOR IF
YOU WILL GET REELECTED PERFORM
BAIL.
IT WAS A BENIGN THING TO DO
EARLY ON.
TILLMAN GO TO JAIL, VIOLENT
OFFENDER SHOULD STAY IN JAIL.
EVER ORGANIZATION I WANT TO
FIGHT CRIME SHOULD BE SAVING.
>> LEADERS OF BLM MOVEMENT IN
BLM.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO PUT BLOOD ON
THE STREETS.
>> Greg: SO CHRIS WALLACE DID
THE CNN PLUS.
AND HAS SOME OF THE PROMISE OF
THE DISH SOME ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD.
WE DO THIS EVERY DAY GET USED
TO.
NUMBER ONE EVERYTHING THAT HE
SAID IS CORRECT.
AND JUDGE IS RIGHT.
WE'VE HAD LIKE THE HIGHEST CRIME
IN 30 YEARS.
WE MET HAVE POVERTY IN
NEW YORK CITY, BUT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST TAXES IN THE COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T BLAME POVERTY OF THE
BLAME THE CORRUPT LIBERAL
LEADERS, IT WOULD LOOK AT AT
THESE HIGH CRIME CITIES MOTHERS
ONE SINGULAR EXAMPLE THAT'S
THERE IN EACH ONE.
SINGLE PARTY RULES.
IF THEY HAVE AND THIS IS A POOR
ANALOGY.
AT THEY HAVE A MOM AND DAD.
IF THERE ARE A PART OF A
REPUBLICAN AND YOU COULD HAVE A
DEMOCRAT.
ONE CAN BE MORE POWERFUL THAN
THE OTHER BUT THERE'S CHECKSUM
IS BALANCES.
IF YOU LET DEMOCRATS RUN
EVERYTHING THEY VERY WORST
INTENTIONS WILL COME TO LIGHT I
SAY THE SAME THINGS ABOUT
REPUBLIK END.
IF THE BALANCE EACH OTHER UP.
NEW YORK CITY HAS NO REPUBLICANS
COUNTERPOINT.
WE LOOK AT PLACES LIKE CHICAGO
OR LOS ANGELES.
THE VERY WORST IDEAS BUBBLE UP
LIKE THE BILL REFORM THING.
THAT ONE OF COME THROUGH THOSE
KIND OF A BALANCE BETWEEN LEFT
AND RIGHT, YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE
MOM AND THE DAD POLITICALLY
TOGETHER TO CREATE THIS.
AND ALSO THE LAST THING ABOUT
THE CRIME IS LOOK AT PLACES LIKE
CNN AND OTHER MEDIA.
THEY DID CHAMPION THE
DEMORALIZATION OF THE POLICE.
THEY BOUGHT INTO IT AND THAT'S
FIELD AT THE FIRST EVER NATIONAL
FERGUSON EFFECT IS WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT PULLS BACK AND
THAT LED TO MORE CRIME AND THE
CRIME EPIDEMIC.
HE DEFINITELY SAID THAT THE
MEDIA HAVE A LARGER SPOT
RESPONSIBILITY IS NOT DISTURBED
BLM'S WITH THAT THE MESSAGE WAS
MUTATED BY THE MEDIA.
>> WHEN YOU ASK HIM ABOUT THE
MAN DOLLAR PENSION AT THE LEADER
PATRICE BOUGHT AND REALLY CAN'T
ANSWER.
HE GAVE HER THE EXAMPLES WHAT
HIS ORGANIZATION IS DOING IN
NEW YORK CITY.
>> Dana: HE WAS ALSO SOMEBODY
WHO BLEW THE WHISTLE ON THE
FUND-RAISING AND HOW THEY WERE
SPENDING THE MONEY AND HE SAID
THAT AT THREE OF THE SEPARATE
THE TWO.
IN A STINK IN THE PUBLIC'S MIND
THAT'S IT DIFFICULT TO DO.
THE CHICKEN AND ALL HIS
INFORMATION IS HARD TO DO.
NOW I ALSO THINK THAT HE IS A
GOOD POINT ABOUT SOMETHING.
HE SAID THAT THERE'S THINGS THAT
HE SENT IN HIS NEIGHBORHOOD
WHICH IS LOCAL SOLUTION, LOCAL
CONTROL TO MAKE SENSE FOR
EXAMPLE IF IN SCHOOL BUT
APPARENTLY IS DOING GREAT
THINGS.
OH COME TO VISIT I LOVE TO DO
IT.
THAT KNOW THE MEDIA WILL, COVER
THAT.
BUT THE COVER HIS OTHER.
HAVING A SON THREE WEEKS IN EVER
YOU ADAMS JUST GOT IN THE ROOM
YES SHE COULD AGREE A LOT MORE.
FOR EXAMPLE MAYOR ADAMS AND PUT
THE APPLAUSE YOU DID WITH THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IS HORRIBLE
NATION OVER SOME THINGS.
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE
TWO LEADERS ONE IS ELECTED ONE
IS APPOINTED ONE IS OBVIOUS THE
CHARISMATIC PEOPLE VIEWED US
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET THEM IN
A ROOM AND BRING SOMEONE
TOGETHER, BRING THEM TOGETHER
THEY MIGHT BE ABLE